What if the stories you remember
changed in a way you'd never forget
t'challa what if the heroes you knew became
something larger than life on august 11th
expect the unexpected that's weird and ask
yourself the question what if streaming august
11th only on disney plus Welcome back everyone
this is my new marvel what if trailer video and
early review breakdown the producers have also
been doing a lot of press explaining how this is
canon to the mcu how that's all going to work so
also explain that too because a lot of people were
wondering whether or not this would be canon to
the mcu because it's animated and they're getting
really crazy with the multiverse so if you were
wondering it is definitely canon i will be doing
videos for all the episodes there'll be nine total
during season one so be sure to subscribe to get
all those if you're brand new to my channel and
i will keep doing the weekly giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave all your predictions
for the series on the video the new trailer
footage also shows us a look at the avengers
during the events or before the events of avengers
infinity war just because of the costumes that
they're wearing like iron man is wearing his
infinity war costume the character designs
look very much like the characters from infinity
war like black widow has the short blonde hair
so because the costumes are similar this is
probably the marvel zombies episode but just
starting with the whole canon of it all because
we just saw the loki series they just established
the king the conqueror is like the next big thanos
level villain the next big avengers level villain
threat for marvel phase four so because of the
way they got so crazy with the multiverse everyone
just wondered how this was going to spill into
the what if series which is also a very multiverse
oriented series the way the producers talked about
it they said that the animated characters would
eventually show up in the live action projects the
live-action movies live-action disney plus series
anybody was fair game so the way they treated
it during the series they visit many different
realities many different universes during the
events of the episodes those are basically
all happening in these different realities that
you see amidst the loki finale here as the true
version of the mcu multiverse is laid bare big hat
tipped to sylvie for setting this all off so the
fact that the series is animated doesn't matter
it's still fully canon to the mcu the same way
that the live-action movies disney plus series
or canon to the mcu like everything crosses over
with the movies help set up future movies this
is just the next step for that it's a big change
from the comics i think a lot of people were just
wondering because the original what if comic book
series is just a series of one-offs they treat
it like elseworld's adventures the things that
happened in the what if stories didn't really
affect what was happening in the main comic book
universe the marvel 616 universe the really funny
thing that producers talked about though like
talking about how crazy they got with the episodes
they said that they actually legit pitched a luke
skywalker cameo inside one of the episodes because
this is what if you could literally do the plot of
that patton oswald filibuster where you cross over
the x-men with the star wars characters in the
original marvel characters but apparently
kevin feige and marvel were not down for the
luke skywalker cameo they're like nope that's too
much can't do that they also said when they were
pitching the plot of some of the guardians of the
galaxy episodes marvel turned them down because
they said the story they had pitched was basically
the plot of guardians of the galaxy 3 the movie
james gunn's getting ready to make they didn't
say what that pitch was only that marvel was like
you just pitched us the plot of guardians of the
galaxy 3. we're already doing all that stuff that
you just talked about in a movie pretty soon which
should give you an idea for how crazy guardians of
the galaxy 3 is going to be i've already done a
couple videos about that so i'll include one of
those links in the description below the producers
also explained that the only thing that they
weren't really allowed to do during the what if
episodes is they couldn't introduce really huge
brand new characters like the x-men the fantastic
four doctor doom namor wolverine deadpool galactus
even though we know all those characters are going
to show up in the marvel movies eventually all the
characters at least during what if season 1 had
to be alternate versions of ones that we've either
already seen as main characters in the movies or
they were side characters or they were mentioned
or canonized in the mcu in some way like howard
the duck is a really good example really just an
easter egg background character just small cameo
scenes in the first couple guardians of the galaxy
movies so he's not really a new character they did
screen the first three episodes early they're each
around 30 minutes long a little bit longer than
the one division episodes if you were wondering
but that half hour run time also includes
the credits episode 1 is what if peggy carter
became captain america instead of steve rogers
because steve rogers gets injured before they can
administer the super soldier serum treatment so
peggy carter steps in then they give skinny steve
rogers what they're calling the hydra stomper
howard stark iron man suit even though it should
have been called the hydra buster i do understand
the logic like it was tony stark who eventually
came up with the buster naming conventions for
all of his armors so howard stark wouldn't have
thought to name something like that back during
world war ii as you can see she fights red skull
arnhem zola the plot is somewhat similar to the
plot of the first captain america movie except we
see a tesseract portal gets opened up by red skull
allowing this tentacle creature through to earth
i've already talked about this in the previous
video i don't think that this is meant to be the
schumacher if it were schumer gorth it would have
a giant eyeball in the middle and it would be way
way bigger when the producers were talking about
these other universe versions of the characters
showing up in live action they talked specifically
about the peggy carter captain carter character
showing up in the live action movies in disney
plus series she's not the only one she's probably
just one of the first ones that you would see in
the live-action movies but they didn't say which
movie so i don't know if that's going to be doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness or if it's going
to be some other future movie after that episode 2
is what if black panther became star-lord instead
of peter quill what if t'challa was really the son
of ego the living planet instead of king t'chaka
as you've seen from the trailer footage jondu
comes to wakanda to pick him up as a child
instead of peter quill in the plot loosely follows
the guardians of the galaxy movie plot the whole
reason why yondu came to earth in the first place
to pick them up was because he was on a mission
ego hired him to return all of his children from
all over the universe when he was doing that giant
3d powerpoint presentation of the weird orgies
that he had all over the universe creating all
those children he basically hired yondu to go
bring those children back so that he could see
if they would be compatible for his mission
that he was trying to take over the universe
that was what all the skeletons were that
gamora and nebula found like all these failed
experiments like none of the other children were
compatible that's also why yandu got kicked out
of that original guardians of the galaxy squad
with sylvester stallone starhawk their team was
based on the og guardians 3000 team from way back
earlier in marvel comics history that predated the
modern incarnation of the team the one that
they based the first mcu guardians movie on
but during the events of the first guardians
movie they explained yondu got sick of trafficking
children for ego and then when he came to get
peter quill and obviously now when he comes to
get t'challa he decided not to take them back and
he raises them like a surrogate father so that's
what we're seeing happen with black panther here
as you probably heard chadwick boseman and michael
rooker both came back to do their voices of the
characters the producers confirmed that chadwick
boseman starred in four episodes total may he rest
in peace obviously he can't come back himself for
season two so if they decide to bring t'challa's
star-lord back in a future season he'd have to be
voiced by a different actor but they didn't really
address how they're going to handle that towards
the end of the series eventually they start
forming this multiverse avengers team with all the
different characters from different universes the
guardians of the multiverses they're calling them
so the roster is going to change every season i
wouldn't worry too much about that right now once
we see all the season 1 episodes i'll talk more
about that like which characters are coming back
during season 2 what the roster is going to be
like in future seasons episode 3 is what if loki
came to earth during the events of the first thor
movie that's why he's wearing his costume from
the first thor movie you've seen the trailer all
this footage of him bringing the asgardian army
to earth using the cask of ancient winters on nick
fury it's just a fun twist on the flashback in the
first thor movie in that prologue scene he's using
the cask of ancient winters on humans the same way
that his father laffy did it is funny watching
the loki footage after seeing all the alternate
versions of loki during the loki series the whole
idea with party thor though in the series the one
that joins the guardians of the multiverse team
is that he is a thor that got his hammer back
without learning his lesson in that first thor
movie so he never reformed and continued to be
the party animal that he was at the beginning of
the movie but as you can see here this is loki
just asserting his dominance over midgard over
earth in a much more successful way than he did
during the events of the first avengers movie with
the shitauri invasion after the avengers had come
together so it's like saying what if loki tried
to conquer earth before the avengers became the
avengers clearly would have been a lot easier
for him i know there's a lot of questions about
what's happening in these alternate realities with
the characters that predate a lot of the marvel
phase one events like what about the eternals like
even if they're on an alternate version of earth
wouldn't the eternals still be there and be able
to stop loki they'll explain a lot of that logic
during the eternals movie later this year when
we actually see it the whole idea with the marvel
what if series is that it's not really changing
the events of what happened in the infinity saga
of movies is showing you what would happen if
events played out differently but using other
universes outside of the main marvel universe
technically the mcu is now a really big multiverse
so it should be called the marvel cinematic
multiverse but i think just for simplicity's sake
it's easier just to continue to refer to it as the
mcu i know during loki episode 1 there was that
616 easter egg they were basically saying that the
original infinity saga version of loki that died
during infinity war was loki but if you've been
following all the mcu movies so far they've been
saying that the mcu is in a different universe
the whole idea is that the main marvel comic book
universe is still the 616 universe i think they're
just calling loki 616 as a subtle wink on that
saying that he's the original main version of loki
but they're not calling this universe the mcu the
616 universe you may have also seen that clark
greg is coming back to do the voice of coulson
he's just coming back because some of the episodes
will cover the events of the early marvel phase 1
movies that featured coulson before he was killed
by loki during the first avengers movie it's not
the older version of coulson coming back after the
events of agents of shield overall the series is
amazing if you liked how crazy they got with the
loki series this obviously takes that way further
i'll be doing weekly episode videos just like i
did for the loki series for all the other marvel
disney plus series all those episodes will post
every wednesday it'll be the exact same schedule
of my videos for the loki series but if you have
any big questions about the what if series just
write them below in the comments and i'll add
that to my future videos there'll be a couple
more trailers probably before episode one drops so
it's gonna be a lot of fun just seeing how crazy
they get with the multiverse episodes i'll name
a new giveaway winner when i post my next marvel
video everyone click here for that brand new
venom let there be carnage trailer and spider-man
easter eggs and click here for my new loki video
about the connection between iron man and kang
inside the mcu thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!